bumblebee was directed by Travis Knight
the man who helmed the excellent Kubo
and the two strings and stars Hailee
Steinfeld and takes place in the 1980s
and follows the Autobot bumblebee as he
stumbles across this young girl's house
finds his voice and fights back against
some Decepticons who have invaded earth
and this young girl learns things about
herself and tries to reconnect with
someone for the first time since losing
her father now I've talked about all the
Transformers movies on my channel before
the original animated film I like as
well as Michael Bay's first film it's
not too bad so since this film takes
place in the 80s has a new director has
a new main star it's able to really
condense a lot of what the Transformers
movies have overblown and this film is
easily the best that I've seen in the
Transformers franchise since the first
one that's not really saying all that
much though considering the quality of
the ones that came after that first one
but this is leaps and bounds above those
and it's a good course correction in
that it understands what the
Transformers fans want to see there's a
feel to that original transformers
cartoon that Michael Bay's films just
didn't understand and bumblebee with
Travis Knight's direction does this
heartwarming sense to it it's not just
nostalgia there's a sense of joy that
this film has that base films just
didn't have there was a cynicism to
those movies a very Hollywood glossy
like overly sexualized appeal to it that
was just gross there's no pot jokes in
this film with parents that are getting
high at college there's no overly
sexualized shots of young women the
color grading is actually correct that's
not highly saturated there's barely any
Dutch angles the action is framed in
wides
and you can actually tell what's going
on it's comprehensible there's no dogs
fucking either which is a major plus and
there's no really annoying characters
that grate on your nerves so much
because they can't stop screaming
there's a lot of benefits to having a
new director on board for this movie
because it's just a new fresh vision and
it's something that I think was missing
from a lot of the transformer
worse films in the past the screenplay
comes from Christina Hudson who in the
past is credited as the writer for
shut-in and unforgettable so I was a
little concerned going in because I
really did not like either of those
films but this is definitely her best
work apparently there was a rewrite on
the film by Kelly Fremont Craig who is
uncredited she wrote and directed edge
of seventeen also with Steinfeld which I
thought was an excellent film so perhaps
that rewrite helped but she did not
receive credit for that and so maybe
they didn't go with her rewrite I don't
know I'm just saying that this
screenplay is better than what Christina
Hudson had done before was shut in and
unforgettable those were two films that
were just like the most throwaway
honestly terrible movies and so it's
nice to see that she's improved a bit
but there are some aspects of this
screenplay that bugged me and some
directions the film takes that I
couldn't help but notice was so much
like other films the biggest and most
obvious comparison is et it is extremely
similar to ET so much so that it almost
feels like the screenplay
looked at Melissa Matheson's original
work with ET and beat for beat recreated
it there's the obvious thing of this
entity that's come from another planet
and a young person discovers it has a
friend feels good about that her father
has passed away and ET Eliot's father
was gone she hides Bumblebee away from
her parents and tries to keep him a
secret just like Eliot and ET eventually
there's a sequence where bumblebee gets
out and trashes the house just like an
et and of course there's a military
subplot just like in all the
Transformers movies but in this one it's
people who are after bumblebee because
they feel that he's a threats and they
have to try to get him out of there and
for most of et you think that these
people who are after ET are evil so I
couldn't help but notice those direct
comparisons they seemed very blatant
there's a few sequences also with
missing information there's a scene
where the mom is taking the dog to the
vet in bumblebee it she doesn't realize
it's bumblebee so Hailee Steinfeld is
trying to get there as quick as she can
on her moped and she catches up to her
mom very quickly and it's like mom scoot
over I'll Drive and she's like oh okay
okay
and then they drive off but I'm like
what happened to the moped did you just
leave it on the street and all honesty
this is a really fun movie the first
half I actually kind of loved
I think the setup is really really good
and I thought Hailee Steinfeld was also
terrific in the movie this is maybe my
favorite performance from her I think
she did a great job I like the family
dynamic that's set up I like her past
she used to be a diver but she doesn't
feel comfortable with that anymore
because it was something her father
encouraged and now that he's not around
it makes her feel depressed and I loved
all the stuff with bumblebee too
the action sequences were all really
well done there's some fight scenes that
I thought were great it definitely
understands the feel of what
transformers is supposed to be this is
actually an enjoyable movie that you can
have a good time watching and not feel
bad about because it's just plain fun
there are some sequences with John Cena
and his military subplot that felt
extremely hammy but I kind of think
they're supposed to be if you ever
actually seen the transformers show it's
corny as hell
it's very cheesy but where Bay's
transformers films and their military
just seemed cringe-worthy and really bad
and fake and stupid here it seems like
they're actually going for the happiness
on purpose as sort of like a
tongue-in-cheek appeal so I would say my
biggest issue with the movie is the
comparisons to ET like if you're going
to have a movie about an entity from
another planet and a young kid is
connecting with it you could at least
try to have the basic subplots and
scenes be in a different order but they
really do feel as if the screenplay for
ET was used as a template almost to just
copy and paste and then change things
around which was disappointing for me
some people may not even notice that
some people may not even care I think
most transformers fans are just gonna be
happy that there's an actual good
Transformers movie out that respects the
legacy and I am happy with this movie
and I can recommend that you'd see it
but I couldn't not notice those
comparisons I'm gonna give bumblebee a B
I think this movie was destined to have
that great it's the perfect grade for
this film I would recommend you see it I
think transformers fans can breathe a
nice
sigh of relief it's nice to see a fun
enjoyable Transformers movie that isn't
a bunch of sparklers and creepy pervy
shots of young girls and the Romeo and
Juliet law oh my god what were they
thinking Jesus Christ anyway guys thank
you so much as always for watching if
you liked this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]